the ukrainian people are being attacked
from the air from artillery from ground
troops and tanks
the debris of this war litters every
street
but the government has warned for days
of russian saboteurs who've infiltrated
the country to bring terror
death squads who are attacking civilians
in their cars as they flee
they do exist
as we found out
no it wasn't it wasn't something blew up
under us
oh
okay
wow
stop
we think it's a ukrainian checkpoint and
a mistake so we identify ourselves
[Music]
is everyone okay
you okay dom
somehow we have to get out of this but
the rounds keep coming it's a
professional ambush the bullets just
don't miss
wow
stop
stop
i'm hit but escape the car and with
producer dominic van hidden we make our
way down the embankment
camera operator richie mockler has taken
two rounds to his body armor but is
still stuck in the car
he runs for it in a hail of bullets
oh
the five of us have made it out of the
car down the embankment and we just
can't believe we're alive
let's go through there behind that wall
we run into a warehouse unit looking for
cover
three caretakers beckon us inside
it's placebo
producer martin val starts coordinating
a rescue plan with sky staff
we know any rescue will take hours we're
stuck
fighting outside we've no idea what's
going on
we've got ourselves into a garage
somehow we found our way in there's
three guys working here and they've said
we can stay with a lot of
firing going on outside
um we don't know why
it appears to be
after a mammoth logistical effort we
were rescued by the local police
we were lucky
thousands of ukrainians are not
and every day this war gets worse here
stuart ramsey sky news kia